هو قرار لم يعجب الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي
ميرسيلز حينما اتفق عليه وكذلك روسيا التي
لم تعره اي اهتمام لكنهم شاؤوا ام ابوا
فان الاتفاق على حظر النفط الروسي بالنسبه
للاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا
دخل حيز التنفيذه مع فرد حد اقصى لسعر
البرميل الواحد على ان لا يتجاوز قدره 60
دولارا ولن يبقى عند هذا الحد بل سيتغير
كل شهرين اعتبارا من منتصفين يناير وباجمع
الاوروبي ومن المفترض ان يتم تحديد السقف
في كل مره عند مستوى اقل بنسبه 5% من سعر
السوق وفقا لبيانات وكاله الطاقه الدوليه
هذا الحظر الذي بدا سا ريانه ضمن حزمه
سادسه من العقوبات الاوروبيه المفروض على
واردات النفط الخام الروسي المنقوله بحرا
اما المنتجات
مكرر المنقوله ايضا عن طريق البحر فستبدا
في فبراير العام القادم وعن استثناءات هذا
الحظر فحصلت عليه بالغاليه التي ستستمر
باستراد خام الاورال الروسي حتى نهايه عام
وتواصل مجموعه من الدول استيراد النفط من
روسيا على طول خط انابيب دروجبا او انبوب
الصداقه كما سمي منذ اكثر من نصف القرن
وتنطبق الاعفاءات على ثلاث دول اعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي الا وهي المجر سوفيا
اتشيكا ذلك الاعتمادها على خط انابيب
النفط من روسيا بسبب موقعها الجغرافي وعدم
قدرتها على استبدال الواردات بسرعه يضاف
اليها اعلان اليابان عن تطبيق الحد الاقصى
للنص الروسي ولكن باستثناء النفط الخام
المستوردي من مصنع خليل اثنين في اقصى شرق
روسيا كون شركات الطاقه اليابانيه تمتلك
حصاصه هناك اذا خفت انتقادات او خفت
الانتقاد الاوكراني لهذا القرار من باب ان
حظرا قليلا افضل من لا شيء لكن روسيا
وبنبره حازمه لن تقبل بالتسقيف الذي سيؤدي
الى حد او على حد تعبيرها الى زعزعه
استقرار اسواق الطاقه العالميه
الثالثه تقريبا
همم
سكست بي ليزر
موسكو ترفض قلبا وقالبا وضع سقفا لاسعار
والكرملين يتحدث عن حزمه اجراءات للرد على
خطوه الغرب بالتاكيد وضعوا سقفا لسعر نفط
الروسي سيضر بالموازنه المحليه خاصه ان
تقارير تتحدث عن انه موسكو تبيعوا بعض من
نفطها بخصوماتهم في الاسواق العالميه حجم
مساهمه النفط في الموازنه الروسيه يصل
قرابه 40% مقابله 12% من الغاز وصارت
الماليه الروسيه تحدثت عن ان ايرادات
النفط والغاز الاضافيه لشهر نوفمبر الماضي
جاءت بنحو 90 مليار روبل تقريبا دون
المستوى المتوقع
قرار الحظر كما يبدو يهدف الى ردع روسيا
عن تمويل عملياتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا
سزامنا مع محاولات اخرى لحل الازمه وبدا
مفاوضات بين موسكو وكياف فبعد ان انهى
الرئيس الفرنسي المكروم زيارته الى واشنطن
للقاء نظيره الامريكي جوبادل اعلنا معا عن
رغبتهما في السعي لتوسل الى انهاء الحرب
في اوكرانيا على طاوله المفاوضات
بايدن الوحيد ان يكون الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتينج جدا بشان نهائي ما اسماء غزوه ثم
جاء رد موسكو سريعا بالرفض على لسان
المتحدث باسم الكرام لاندمث مع قوله ان
بلاده ليست مستعده للدخول في محادثات اذا
كان شرط واشنطن ان تغادر روسكو روسيا
اوكرانيا لكن تصريح اخر لمكرون في احد
المقابلات التلفزيونيه اثار حفيظه
الاوكرانيين اذا لم نقل غضبه حدث مكروه عن
انه يجب تفهم وضع روسيا حول مخاوفها
والضمانات الامنيه لاجراء محادثات الفعاله
على عكس اوكرانيا وموقفها الصريح بان
المفاوضات لن تبدا الا بانسحاب القوات
الروسيه عن اراضيهميها اليكسي دانيلو
مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع الاوكراني كان
احد الرافدين بجراه لاقوال مكروم واعتبر
انها تنطلق من افواه لمنطق غريب
للدبلوماسيه كان قد ولا زمنه وتسائل كيف
يريدون توفير ضمانات امنيه لدوله ارهابيه
وقاتله بل ويطلبون منا بدلا من نورمبرج ان
وقع اتفاقيه مع روسيا ونصافحها يتساءل
مضيفا ان الدماء الاوكرانيه على ايدي بوتن
غير مهمه كالعاده ويعارض الكثيرون في
اوكرانيا والغرب بشده اجراء اي مفاوضات مع
بوتن من شانها ان تكافئه بتنازلات بعد حرب
عمرها اقترب من اتمام عام باكمله ويعتبر
ما قاله مكروم يعتبر رد وصفه بعض
الاوكرانيين بالعاطفين مع حاجه موسكو الى
ضمانات امنيه وانه اخذ وقتا طويلا ففي
فبراير العام الماضي وجها بوتن رساله
لنظره الفرنسي خلال احد المؤتمرات التي
جمعتهما افاد حينها بان روسيا ستواصل
محاوله الحصول على اجابات من الغرب على
مطالبها الامنيه الثلاثه الرئيسه والتي
تنص على ان لا مزيد من التوسع لحلف شمال
الاطلسي ولا انتشار الصواريخ بالقرب من
حدودها اضافه لتقليص البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه لحلف الاطلسي في اوروبا الى
مستويات عام 1997 لكن بالرغم من ذلك مكروه
لم ياتي باي خيط يشير الى ان فرنسا ستتوقف
عن دعم اوكرانيا رغم مساعه نحو مفاوضات
بين الطرفين